what's up dylan how are you doing hey dr
d how are you
i'm good brother how are you oh it's
just another day
it's just another day well listen this
is important
the astros are going to beat the dodgers
this year so there's that all right so
what's up man how can i help
i don't know about that i'm an angels
fan they just whipped them
they super dude man they did good
good call for those of you don't know
the astros played the angels last night
and the angels beat them and it was
embarrassing it was a good comeback win
good for them
all right brother so how can i help
dylan man you clowned me on that uh
i am 23 years old and i've been divorced
for about a year and a half
my age is 19 through 22 were pretty bad
and that included divorce however
i've been with my current girlfriend for
about 18 months
um i have been getting some comments
here and there
when are you guys going to get married
what are you going to propose blah
and i thought about it for a couple
weeks hey dylan
talk directly into the phone man
can you hear me now ah way better
perfect okay all right
um i've been getting some comments about
getting married when you're going to
propose
and i thought about it for a couple
weeks and i realized i am absolutely
terrified of getting married again
because of
my last marriage which was completely
self-inflicted i have
i have accepted that and dealt with that
but i was wondering how would i get over
the fear um of getting married again the
fear that
that that might end up really badly
again yeah man
i appreciate your question dude people
all
over planet earth are going through this
right now um it's been a rocky season
for relationships and people trying to
grow something new out of the ash man so
i appreciate your heart on this
um who's making these comments
oh just just some family members and
friends no not like uh
they're kind of joking but it just got
me thinking seriously about it
why do you care what they think if
you're not ready right now you're not
ready
what why are you giving audience to
those those
critical voices i guess i take a lot of
i think a lot of what people say i know
i shouldn't and i try not to but i guess
i take
based off of my past marriage and
and how it ended my military career and
it was just really bad based on that i
guess i take a lot of heart to what
people think because
grew it up so badly over the last couple
years that i just
i take to heart a lot of what people
think and i shouldn't it's a bad
it's not a good thing to do what
happened in your previous one man
uh well i mean i was in the army i was
stationed out there at fort campbell
actually and uh
i got back from deployment started
drinking a lot
and it just i wasn't the best husband we
had a we had
my son and then shortly after that it
just fell apart and we separated
and then divorced six months later okay
so you ran around on her too
uh yeah yeah yeah okay now and here's
what i'm trying to get at the bottom of
um when you have a situation where
a marriage implodes right and you may
have heard me say this before and i'll
keep saying it over and over because we
don't talk about it enough as a
as a culture when a marriage implodes
when a relationship that you care about
implodes
when you do something you never thought
you would do which is cheat on somebody
that you love
especially the mother of your kid right
no one ever sets that sets out for that
right um
you lose trust in the relationship right
and you have the the
normal grief and you know picking up the
pieces after a train wreck
of an ended relationship but beneath
that you're you're kind of hinting
around the edges here
you lose trust in you you're like who is
this guy
right i thought this guy i thought i was
better than that
i thought that i was fill in the blank
and suddenly you betrayed yourself right
you stumbled and you thought you were
running just fine
and now you're in a new relationship you
like this person you're a year and a
half in it's cool and all great
but you don't trust dylan anymore and
now you're trying to outsource that
trust to
other people man and that's when people
find themselves way over their head
making stupid decisions
because you give audience to idiots
right we all do it man
um but that one buddy who's like seven
beers in it's like bro why don't you get
married and you're like i don't know man
maybe i
should right or some uncle that you
wouldn't even
if he called you with a good deal on a
car you'd be like uh no
but he makes a comment about some right
and so um
you start giving you start giving
audience to other voices
i really want to see dylan learn to
trust dylan man so what'd you learn from
the last
situation
would you learn about what did you learn
about you
i learned that oh man
i learned to own up a lot i learned to
take accountability
of what i do not try to
bury myself deeper lie to try to make it
worse
to cherish and not take for granted the
people we love
and and the basic things like you know i
have my house my family
not to take things like that for granted
um and just just not to
screw up things that that you love and
you cherish and just
yeah yeah so listen brother the
you just talked about responsibility you
talked about wisdom you talked about
accountability
and you've learned it the hard way but
if you start to wrap your head in a real
way
around those lessons those commitments
at age
23 you're ahead of more than
any you're you're ahead of most of
society look around brother
nobody will take accountability nobody
will make wise choices
nobody will say hey i screwed this up i
have to be better next time
and you have right so give me
one example of what not taking for
granted what cherishing a relationship
what does that look like how are you
treating this new person differently
than the old person
um well i mean
she never opens her car door anymore i
always open it for her okay
give me something way more i mean that's
cool that's that's
chivalrous and i i support that i'm an
old texas kid man so i'm high fiving you
uh give me something deeper than that uh
we actually talk
when we when we get home for the day we
talk about how our day went
if if one of us has an issue with the
other
we sit down and we discuss what the
issue is and what we're going to go from
here
which i never never did in my last
marriage you know what that's called
brother that's called vulnerability man
and you know what that is that is the
soil of a relationship that's gonna work
right that you plant in that soil you
can plant any kind of crazy seeds in
that kind of soil
and if you as a 23 year old guy
it's going to make you a great dad it's
going to make you a great co-parent with
your ex who's going to be healing from
what you did for
for years and it's going to make you a
great future husband
that is what i'm talking about man
that's wisdom that's accountability
that's
learning man good for you dude good for
you
so here's here's the the quick brain
science you got bit in the face last
time
you reached way down to kiss a
rattlesnake and it bit you in the face
and it hurt and it sucked and
you went through a lot of garbage and
you hurt people that you loved
your brain has a vested interest in you
never getting near that rattlesnake
again
ever ever so every time you think about
getting married
of think about a committed relationship
your brain is going to sound every alarm
it's got
okay just know that is your body trying
to take care of you
it's trying to love you the best it
knows how okay
you are still learning how to be in a
relationship my guess is your parents
didn't model this for you is that fair
or maybe they did yes okay so you're
flying blind
you're on a mission with with no map
on what a vulnerable southern california
dude looks like
in a committed relationship right
yeah okay so here's the deal
i can give you a hundred percent
guarantee that you never get hurt again
you want
it this is a hundred percent guarantee
you will
never get hurt again okay
break up with your girlfriend now and
never be in another relationship again
ever that's a hundred percent guarantee
that you never get hurt
it also is a hundred percent guarantee
that you will never love never get
connected
and you will be miserable the research
tells me you'll die younger
and you'll ultimately hate your life and
so the way to get over the fear
of getting married again getting close
and super connected with somebody
is to do exactly what you're doing you
gotta
practice being a better partner
every single day and when you practice
it
and you continue to die to yourself and
let her be
more important than your temper tantrums
and her be more important than your
anger
and her being more important than
responding to that text from that woman
that you know you shouldn't respond to
because you know where it's gonna go
when she's more important than one more
beer and one more beard one more beer
when you die to that self and she
becomes number one
right then brother you are just
planting seeds and you're taking care of
that soil and that sucker is going to
grow and grow and grow and eventually
your body's going to say
oh dude this isn't life-taking this is
life-giving
we're all in on this thing and then at
some point brother you got a risk
because every relationship is risk
and so you got to get back in the ring
again 18 months sounds
super quick to me how long have you been
divorced
uh almost almost two years
okay officially officially divorced yeah
yeah
um what's the rush man
i mean there's no really there's no rush
i mean i know as of right now i do want
to marry her but i
i just figured i'd face it now that that
i am i am pretty scared
okay so man think of it as
the first time you did rifle training
and you held that rifle too far from
your shoulder and you pulled the trigger
and it kicked back and almost took your
arm with it right
and the only way to do that better the
next time is to hold that thing
real tight and that's scarier for your
body and you do it you do it you do it
and then pretty soon
you start getting nervous before you
pull trigger on that gun right and so
it's both in honor your honor the fact
that your body is terrified of getting
to a relationship again
honor the fact that 18 months is real
quick
right that you're still growing and
you're still learning
and also honor the fact that there is no
grand adventure in life there is no deep
reckless
wild insane love there is no hard
seasonal rises with the with the waves
in the ocean
rad 50 year old marriage that doesn't
come with
wild putting it all out their risk all
in
and i'm going all in on you and in your
case you've been all in before
but you only had like a two and a three
and a six and you went all in
because you you weren't playing right
and you lost big
and now you're gonna have to get better
cards and you're gonna practice those
cards and you're gonna go all in
your heart's right brother you're in the
right place dylan keep taking baby steps
keep practicing
and here's another magic thing be
vulnerable with
let your current girlfriend know where
your head's at hey we're we're
a year and a half in i think you're the
person for me forever and i'm terrified
because i screwed her up so bad last
time
what are some ways i can continue to get
better do something
real crazy go see a marriage counselor
with her a pre-marriage counselor see if
y'all are on the same page
begin to get some new skills and some
more skills and some more skills man
i've been married for a long long time
i'm still learning new skills
it's all about what the seasons are
going to bring and am i ready for the
weather
when it comes so grateful for your heart
brother you give me hope dylan
so glad you're out there